привіт я даша мені 22 я намагаюся дме
опіка
на іншому курсі поривалась вони крали
мета нуцці було нас правдивим і просто
здатного для бабуся то я просто фанат
комунальних крила з не
дуже люблю проти то рукам і ну і
якось так я б вирішила що пізніше
займаєтеся а сама мета
підкорялася все так після школи я б
вирішила поїхати у місця хочуть та
самостійно жити а що було в університеті
потім билан змінивши корінням сподіваєшся
проти ловити on
від таня таня по метаєш від нього
невеликий показував ок розкочують тісто
на штрудель вона була супер танка я за
зростання багнета у світ про цю
[музика]
статті каркаю квітково 1с краще кришне
моєму жити і якщо обрізати і волосся його в
восьмому класі відомо
на роботі я сливами людина в будинку тут
тепло та душевно
класно тільки ти все храмкова this to
which уват і запах свіжою випічкою
щодо цього прийому не клієнти так їх злих
і новизни його бійці
[музика]
а
станемо годинником сама біржа показового
то вода не гарчи і кира не створювалося до
тесту завжди будуть рідше в магазині
транспорт на ходу вона ж світла в будинок
слухайте я ж дарую людям щастя за в
дикої розуму не всі противник trouble
[музика]